[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and this is a very
special video that we created in
collaboration with pro manga artist
Cuusoo Marie we all know the powerful
story of Mellie Otis and Elizabeth and
their timeless undying love but have you
ever thought about what their baby would
look like and what kind of powers the
baby would have there will be some manga
spoilers in this video about the demon
and goddess clans so that we can take
all of the information into
consideration so please proceed with
caution
seeing as how malleolus is the son of
the demon king and one of the strongest
demons ever and Elizabeth is the
daughter of the supreme deity the ruler
of the goddess clan
what kind of crazy power could we expect
to see from a child of Mellie Otis and
Elizabeth for the past few weeks I
worked together with pro manga artist
Kusama need to come up with a concept
and character design for a potential son
of Mellie Otis and Elizabeth and because
Mellie Otis is the sin of wrath for now
we will just call his son the son of
Wrath whose omen II has drawn an awesome
character designed for the Sun of wrath
and you will be seeing that design
during the course of this video and by
the way if you want to help us come up
with a name for this new character just
follow us on Twitter and Instagram at
anime uproar we will be taking your name
suggestions there and then we will pick
our favorite suggestions and we will
have a poll on Twitter to decide how to
call the Sun of wrath also be sure to
check out who so many social media he is
an incredibly talented and hardworking
artist his links are in the description
and joining me today for this discussion
we have my good friend Knox Taku hello
thank you so much for having me pleasure
to be here
great - I'm not talking about seven
deadly babies yes love it as always good
to have you and this is a especially
challenging analytical demanding video
and I need your expertise for this one
well it's my pleasure to assist you
great okay so the closest in the series
that we've come to a hybrid of any kind
was basically mile with the commandments
inside his body we also had the humans
who injected themselves with demon blood
which in some cases gave them more power
in other cases it killed them in the
other cases of gaming power first and
then they turn into monsters later so
that's basically all we have to go on in
terms of what a hybrid demon goddess
would look like yes because in anime
it's far more likely that there will be
some God person with evil powers imbued
within them creating a new personality
than actually settling down and having
children so this is very understandable
well I mean it is a shounen so you know
you got to get creative with it but so
one thing that I noticed with my own but
he was definitely powerful because he
had the commandments and the goddess
body but his goddess body also seemed to
be rejecting the commandments and this
clearly affected his mental state so the
more Commandments he absorbed the more
he just went completely insane and also
the more his body seemed to be
deteriorating on the distrain of the
commandments right yeah 100% and also I
think it's because he lost his memories
too like he didn't know he was supposed
to be using goddess powers at any point
yeah so that's another aspect of it like
he didn't have his memories he had it he
did remember Elizabeth and like she had
dreams of him so there was this like
weird connection there but he didn't
have his memories but there was
something off about him and you know the
other demons like cusack noticed that
said there was something off about esta
rosa from the beginning so that is also
something that's interesting it's like
he had the commandments everyone thought
that he was a demon but the fact that he
is in fact a goddess there was something
there that made the jumped out even at
other demons that something wasn't quite
right there so this seems to tell us
that goddess and demon powers are not
necessarily compatible look I guess it's
his subconscious that couldn't be fully
erased by go there I I don't know if
it's the compatibility per se and also
because they're both not natural to him
I mean he's only naturally a goddess
this demon power thing oh is something
that was imbued within him at a later
date
someone who would you know for example
naturally be inclined to both goddess
and demon powers for example
there is a demon and the father is a
goddess totally original situation that
never will happen anywhere but that
could potentially lead to someone
harnessing both powers yes so it is not
interesting scenario to think well
because he would genetically have
naturally the you know the genetics of
demon and a goddess but when we look at
demon and Goddess powers so for example
the goddesses have the ability to purge
and essentially they purge Dark Souls
like the souls of demons the question is
then if the goddess power seems to be
particularly geared towards purging and
destroying Dark Souls like the Dhokla
souls of demons how could that affect
potentially the Sun of Wrath as we're
calling the Sun the potential son of
Elizabeth and Mellie Otis well I highly
suggest him to never Pat himself on the
back or he might accidentally knock his
Dark Soul out no but aside from that as
far as knocking the Dark Souls out of
enemies that could work I don't see any
issue there one interesting thing that I
was thinking about when I was talking
with Cuusoo Mary what we were first
coming up with the concept for this
character who so mary brought up the
idea that potentially the darkness
inside the son of Wrath's body could be
focused in one particular area such as
in one eye and then so essentially this
would allow the Sun to function normally
without constantly being at war with
himself but the darkness is still there
dormant let's say in one eye and then it
away it awakens when he becomes angry
for example or something like that and
then he becomes more powerful but
potentially his mind state deteriorates
and he becomes more unstable and another
thing that is interesting to consider we
know from the seven deadly sins world
that the demon power seems to be
stronger at night so perhaps the Sun
during the daytime is able to keep it
more in check but then at nighttime sort
of like a reverse
esken or the demonic power gains more
strength and this effects his power and
his mood that very well could be that
that's actually a very interesting take
on it I don't know if it would
completely block out the other part of
himself I mean I could see it has you
know his demon powers are stronger
at night whereas his goddess powers are
stronger during the day I don't know
that they would necessarily be all only
one or the other and also if you
remember Mellie Otis is pretty much the
only character that only went crazy
freak out demon mode when he got angry
everyone else pretty much had these
demon powers you know just like the
goddesses had goddess powers
Mellie Otis just had to seal away his
powers because it was he was afraid that
he'd get angry and accidentally Nuka
continent again which sucked for that
first continent by the way the kingdom
of denna 4 yeah rip kingdom of data for
sorry fam sorry
so yeah that's an interesting point
because again Mellie Otis is the the sin
of Wrath and he is known for you know
almost ironically he's this calm
fun-loving guy who is known for when he
loses his temper bad things happen
because he is so powerful and I would
assume you know that a character that is
the son of melea would also have these
wrath issues so that's why we're calling
him lovingly the son of Wrath so I could
definitely see something happening like
at night his demonic power is stronger
so while it doesn't overcome his goddess
powers completely if he gets angry or
something then he becomes more demonic
and he's kind of struggling with himself
because let's face it a character who is
half goddess and half demon would be
extremely powerful or they'd cancel each
other out and he would have absolutely
no powers but let's talk about that
you're pretty boring with you it's like
so they would cancel each other out and
he would have no and our conclusion he
is powerless thank you all so much for
coming definitely like it subscribe yeah
and check out Knox Taku but with other
brilliant video ideas but assuming that
he does have powers
I think it will be very cool to see kind
of like making him I character that is
kind of at war with himself right
because even though he will be powerful
he could be a complex character if he
has to deal with these two sides in an
interesting way where maybe sometimes
his power is limited because of the fact
that the two sides are at war with each
other
other times the power may be out of his
control and he does things that he
regrets and then he wants to make up for
those things so I see a lot of
character development potential with
something like this yeah for sure
I mean as far as Elizabeth's personal
you know psychological state there's
nothing too fascinating there at least
for me she's just a pretty easygoing
individual Mellie Otis is the
fascinating guy at least psychologically
so for all you know a kid of these two
characters could have more of the
Elizabeth jeans and just be this you
know content submissive bozo Elizabeth
does do some interesting things back
when she's a goddess right she stands up
that a goddess clan to defend some of
the demons that she feels like are not
evil
so she does do some interesting things
but yeah but they're all just like moral
high-ground stuff there's there's no
real psychological turmoil within her
like you have Mellie Otis in the
beginning he's this happy fun-loving guy
and it's all a facade because he doesn't
want to accidentally screw up and who
will get a repeat of what happened at
data Ford we don't want that so Mellie
Otis is a really interesting character I
mean the way he went through his
training art to get his powers back is
he had to suffer the loss of his love
again and again and again until he can
hold himself back and he starts crying
at that point that's insane I agree with
you 100 percent I think Mellie Otis is
the more interesting character Elizabeth
just seems to be overall like a good
person kind caring which is all good but
it's not as kind of complex and as
interesting as meliodas so I would like
to think that the son of man the oldest
and Elizabeth would have traits of both
by that potentially in certain
situations like at night or when he's
angry he would kind of get like a crazy
demonic side to him and that would be
just part of his charm and part of his
development as a character right so I
think it would be really cool if being
that demons are more powerful at night
and goddesses are more powerful during
the day maybe the son of rats actual
genetic makeup would make him more demon
like at night and more goddess like
during the day like during the day he's
this happy fun-loving pushover type
morally righteous fellow and then at
night he becomes a little edgier but if
he gets pissed that night oh we get more
Kingdom of data for stuff happening
yeah and that's actually really cool
because we already have precedent with
some like that with Eska nor so I would
love to see him and esken or go on like
a long road trip together we're assuming
esken or ever gets his sunshine be
assuming so then in the during the
daytime s can ORS like pushing him
around like come on buddy
night revenge time yes they're pretty
cool like OVA right there because knocks
I know that you're an anatomical expert
mostly for female characters but you
know let's try one here for a male
character how many hearts do you think
that the Sun of wrath would have so
being that my anatomical skills are
first rate i would say that since demons
have seven hearts and goddesses have one
heart that means the kids would have
eight hearts because seven plus what are
they oh that's interesting
there we go they're just like excuse me
I'm one with ten fingers marry someone
else with ten fingers the kids have
twenty fingers there we go
oh it will do college was worthwhile
there you go very much very true the
truth is it would only need one heart
because one heart can love infinitely
the more you know such a nice wholesome
ending we'll have to put some piano
music while you say that but the reason
I ask the hard question is because we
know that if demons sacrifice six of
their hearts they can become Endora
so to undergo the Enduro transformation
which as long as they're over 50,000
power level they can become this insane
beast that is even way more powerful
than their regular form so I'm just
wondering whether the Sun of wrath would
be able to undergo such a transformation
or whether that would be blocked by the
goddess side or whether the endure are
created by such a sacrifice would be
some kind of mutant angelic demon beast
of greatness
I like the demon beast of greatness
thing but think about it if it's
actually eight hearts then what if they
sacrifice seven hearts that makes them
super Endora hmm Super Saiyan Indira I
like that way I think the concept of
having like a son or daughter of
Yodas an Elizabeth or potentially Merlin
and Eskin or stuff like that is very
interesting for me to think about so
thank you Knox for joining me for this
video where we clearly delved very deep
and very skillfully into the and Atomics
personality powers of this potential Sun
of wrath if I were to ask you what name
you would give this character if you
were the one to choose do you have any
idea Mellie is a bit I just came up with
imagine the next season where it was all
just part of the plan of some super
demon king but the base demon king that
we know until now is just under his
control and who is the only person that
can stop the super mega demon king bori
Otis the son of Mellie Otis yes totally
not ripping up any other shown in here
yes and in fact adopted would stop
referring to my oldest is Mellie Otis
and we were just started calling him
bori Otis as dad yeah and it would be
very sad I'm sure bori Otis his
backstory would be tragic because as we
know Mellie Otis has to work so hard
saving the world every day and doesn't
have time for his son so his son becomes
a stuck up loser
kind of like bored oh well hopefully not
hopefully not but we'll have to wait and
see actually I wanted to invite
everybody to give us your ideas for what
name this character should have the son
of Wrath the son of Elizabeth and Molly
Otis give us your ideas on Twitter and
Instagram at anime uproar the links to
that thread are in the description so
just reply with your ideas we'll pick
our four favorites let's say and we'll
do a Twitter poll where you can vote and
then from that point on if we're gonna
refer to this character by that name
what do you think of that Knox SiC idea
I will definitely be voting and I'm kind
of leaning towards smelly Otis alright
we'll see well thank you very much Knox
for helping out with this this was a
really fun video and a fun collab that
we did with Cuusoo Monty check him out
links to his social media in the
description including the video where he
shows you exactly how he drew the whole
thing with his own commentary links in
the description show him some love
hell yeah also who so many created at
shirt design for us of the Sun wrath
that you can now purchase right there on
our website
animail procom if you want to support
the channel and also get this shirt with
a character that no one else will have
because we created them together so no
one else could possibly have it so there
you go you would be completely original
Knox Taku thank you for joining us
tell the wonderful people the kind of
great things you do on your YouTube
channel Knox Taku I do great things
check it out talk about anime definitely
linked to Knox Taku also in the
description and until next time see us
bass cowboys and stay weird BAM
[Music]
you
[Music]